So it started with a hilariously
awkward picture of John Green
pretending to write in the most
uncomfortable position possible,
a photo that was taken for an article about
him in the Hollywood Reporter,
so congratulations for that, John.
Then my girlfriend, Emily, thought
that it would be funny
for me to copy his pose
in our own picture.
I put it on the internet with
the hashtag "#Johning,"
and I guess that Twitter must have
been having a particularly slow week
because, for some reason,
it became it's own little meme.
While I am definitely proud, I think,
of the success of Johning,
I'm less happy about the fact that I think
it is the most successful project
I've working on in...let's just
say quite a while.
The problem that I've been
experiencing is that
all of the ideas that I've had
recently that I actually like
have been for things that I just do not have
the skills required to actually accomplish.
For example, my ideas for a website
and for a video game.
As much as I do definitely feel like just
some dumb kid who doesn't
understand how ambitious and difficult
his "cool" ideas actually are,
I still feel like I have to try and so,
I'm going to pitch my ideas to you
because I don't know
what else to do.
Firstly: the website.
So just like everyone else who
uses YouTube regularly,
I have a bit of a love/hate
relationship with the website,
and, more than anything, I'd really like them
to have some proper competition
in the hopes that it might encourage
them to up their game a bit.
But, obviously, you can't make just
another video streaming website
and hope it does
a well as YouTube.
There has to be something different
enough about it to justify it existing.
And so I asked myself, "What is the one thing
that I would change about YouTube if I could?"
and I decided that I would want
to get rid of view counts.
Instead, the videos on my hypothetical
website would be ranked
based on overall engagement.
So, a view would actually be
worth the least because,
although you are engaging with the content,
it's only in a very passive way.
And the longer you watch something,
the more that view would be worth
because the more
engaged you are.
If you click "like" on a video, that would
be worth more engagement than a view
because the video is actually encouraging
you to take some kind of action.
If you share a video, that's worth more
engagement, if you leave a comment,
the longer and better written your comment is,
the more engagement it's worth,
and if you decide to leave a video response,
that's the most engaged you can be
because you've actually been
encouraged to create something new
based on what you've seen.
And so all of that data would be
put through an algorithm,
that would come up with an
engagement rating for a video,
and that number would be the big one that
would appear underneath the video
as opposed to a view count.
I think that to start with, it would just
have to rank existing online videos
as opposed to hosting all of its own stuff, but,
yeah, that's my website. Now the video game.
So you play as a ghost who died hundreds of
years ago in this big old warehouse building,
and it's been so long now since you've
did that two things have happened:
you've completely forgotten
about your past,
so you can't remember what
you're unfinished business is,
and the warehouse in
which you died
has since been converted into
a block of trendy apartments.
And so the gameplay would be
that you'd be able to wander freely
and around all of these
people's apartments,
observe their lives, and then decide
to haunt them however you like.
For example, you're
wandering around,
you discover somebody trying to
break into someone else's apartment,
you scare the hell out
of them, they run away.
Or you could wander into someone's
apartment, observe them,
discover that they are procrastinating
from putting up their shelves,
you can wait until
they're gone,
and then you can haunt them nicely
by putting their shelves up.
Even as someone who's only
ever played video games,
I can see a lot of potential
issues in the idea,
but I still really like the general
concept of like a ghost simulator,
and it feels like the kind of story
that would just work best
if told through a video game
for whatever reason.
So if there is anybody out
there who thinks
they'd be able to make these ideas
a reality, please do get in touch,
and if there's anybody out there
who wants to steal these ideas,
I guess I'm making it pretty
easy for you to do that,
so I will ask you
politely not to.
Because, like I said, I don't
know what else to do here.
Thank you very much for
your potential help,
and let's hope the ideas
don't die with this video
'cause that would be sad.
Goodbye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
A lot of you have probably
noticed this already,
but I will now confirm it for you.
I bought the lights.
I'm not sorry.
Thank you for watching.
If you'd like to watch my previous video,
you have ten seconds to find it. Good luck.
[CLOCK TICKING SOUNDS]
It was here all along,
and you're terrible at finding things.
Sorry...I mean deal with it.